honey then we gonna have a good time a
dozen hands up to the sky we gonna chose
did you know kill a babe we got a spark
a little ride let away
I'm counting down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she feels like I've been walking on ice
wanna let everything go and feel alright
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday
it is finally right here in New York but
it is dark in our souls because there is
you know just terrible news have I just
I'm I'm actually speechless actually
speechless like the news that we're
about to deliver today is like something
that I think in the back of my head I
probably knew was coming I never knew
this was coming I I had thought about it
um but I never expected actually how
devastated I would feel that Rascal
Flatts are breaking up like is that what
you call we're just they're breaking
they're retiring but really waking up
implies like bad blood but I think
they're all like very happy together I
just think like it is time you know like
it's over the party's over
it's so [ __ ] devastating you guys
like at least they announced a farewell
tour they're giving all their fans a
last minute chance to see them it's just
it's honestly not enough it's not very
short or it's now become like part of my
summer to go and see them and their
summer playlist and also like this also
means no more new music like luckily
their catalogue is so stellar that I can
listen to their songs until I think they
have so many albums but it's
heartbreaking stuff like that
their music is the soundtrack to my life
like especially the last decade they're
the reason why we even like country
music in the first place it's just like
it's the sort of thing that breaks the
heart and I don't know what to do
because it's so out of my hands right
know that I was like yes I wanted to
like be helpful my should I start a
petition because you know when I've ever
I feel in doubt I just started petition
like the only thing that could make this
worse is if like a band is just doing it
to do it right and I just honestly I
feel like in the last few years Rascal
Flatts has just been so disrespected by
like everyone everyone and this also
means that our dreams of them performing
at stagecoach gone oh my god totally I
mean a great way to you know end the
Bands career would have been a
stagecoach headlining moment but we
already got the stagecoach post like in
three years we're just gonna come
together one night only I just really
hope that there is no bad blood because
if there is and they break up like we're
never gonna see them together again not
even a farewell like not even a reunion
but if they're just like brothers who
like are over it maybe there's some hope
for us in the future I think they're
brothers who are over it's really tiring
like I go to their show and I'm sweating
they do a summer show it's every year
and like I can't imagine how they feel
like they're the ones working ot so I
understand and I don't think there's bad
blood because they all went on CBS 2
together to talk about and they're do
act it's over yeah so I don't think it's
bad blood I think they're really just at
the age of retirement like you know they
you know they're old and I follow carry
on Instagram and he has a daughter and
she's a huge BTS fan and he's always
like pulling his strings to get her
going to BTS shows it's all fine it's
all good I'm just like literally
devastated I'm fine and it's not good
right um and it's just heartbreaking for
some of us and I think my goal for 2020
I know we were trying to figure out some
yesterday and now I have one but also I
have a goal for 2020 my goal for 2020 is
to see Rascal Flatts five times before
the end of this farewell you want to see
them obviously in the New York area
wherever you playing they're playing
James each and hometown New Jersey then
I think that we should go to Red Rocks
they're performing in Vegas which we
will be attending okay when are they
performing in Vegas Kelly Clarkson
weekend on the tour no it's just a
performance because the heli Clarkson
Jordan I didn't know what you were
talking about Kelly Clarkson we can
understand okay because we're going to
the premier weekend of Kelly Clarkson's
invincible and I decided last night like
that will bring me the most joy in my
life I'm just looking for Joyce
experience what was your reunion
what was your resolution for 2025 Rascal
Flatts toes very specific before they
before they're no more so I have before
that I'm definitely gonna go to and then
I think the fifth might be their final
final show in West Palm weight and I
just love a West Palm moment it's not
like we do play somewhere inconvenient I
feel as though we should just go to West
Palm any again yeah well they're having
space palm as well well no since the
Mortimer says you can't go there it also
reminded me yeah go to West Palm she
said yesterday I I remember an actual
resolution I want to have because I know
I like said that I'm too good for
resolutions and like I am but I I came
up with one that I think is good and
it's actually the opposite I think last
year one of my resolutions was like just
say no to life like stop doing things
that like not that don't bring me joy
but also that just like physically
intense like leaving my house but I
think like I did too much of that last
year I think I said no to like a lot of
things that I should have said yes to
and now I'm think
like my resolution should be to say yes
like I'm leaving the house now two week
nights in a row like two things like
that I just obviously I would rather be
in bed but you know I think it's better
that I get out and socialize like I went
to dinner last night with my friend
Simon at the catch steak by the way
which do you think I have a kosher steak
how do coasters take me and Ben split it
it was two hundred and fifty dollars and
we're really thinking about not getting
it but no restaurants have a question so
you can try it you guys don't get it
then they're gonna take it off the menu
okay but it really was not that great
the restaurant was amazing no like
stunning literally stunning huge very
toasty great service I really recommend
it it was an elevated experience what
made it toasty lots of toasters oh oh it
was a pig in green here toasting there
toaster there just no not pick a green
it's just a dairy toasty filled with
toasters and I haven't seen my friend
Simon in film so long so like because I
never leave my house like I just need to
I think I need to start leave my house
more unfortunately I can appreciate that
but I think in general our role of
saying no to life really includes like
those may influence your immense 7 get
invited to and it's like I will maybe go
to one a year and it just makes me even
more sure in my resolve that we need not
be going to those things but I agree I
can step out for dinner more I'm still
saying no to those things because when I
say yes to life that's not life I just
mean like seeing my friends more like
I'm such a hermit and when I get home
from working like I just don't want to
leave the house yeah and I think that's
a bad way and I haven't seen so many of
my friends in like a year yeah it's not
nice it's not nice and then I wonder why
I have so few friends then part of my
resolution like piggybacking off of that
is the more trips which is what inspired
me to go to Vegas to see my girl Kelly
Clarkson at one point I didn't think
anyone was gonna come with me and I was
really gonna go alone because it's like
I don't think I will ever be as happy as
the premiere of the invincible show
which is her whole catalog I just can't
wait you know I'm very down together
birthday weekend reduce sweet life like
su ite that night that we stayed in when
we went by the way that's already what I
looked at to book was it available
it looks available but it looks to be so
much more expensive than when we stayed
there Jackie and I went to the Billboard
Music Awards straight from stagecoach we
were exhausted we just got a random
hotel room and when we were there we
were like giving up great it's like
Vegas feets are so crazy and they're
really not usually that expensive
because there's a million and we were
staying at the Encore and they were like
actually have an apartment suite and I
was like him and we were so exhausted we
were like it was little bit about 170
dollars more a night like you really we
got literally
Falacci a two-bedroom suite Caesars
Polachek living room dining room massage
room extra bathroom here extra bathroom
there ensuite
that's have literally sickening
sickening now every time I watch
people's stories who go to Vegas
everyone stays in that room because um
Diplo and the chainsmokers both have
presidencies at excess in the hotel they
stay in that hotel room every night and
there's only two in the hotel I don't
know how we got it I don't know it's
just like the guys are smiling down on
us because we were working so hard we
were yeah it was but it was amazing and
that's what we need for when we go to of
course like like a five stars all the
way for me also before we jump in and
we're eating myself to Kelly Clarkson
okay we - yes of course and then I was
looking on VIP tables and you like eight
tables a table for the show you can get
a table and a dessert table in Vegas you
can get anything but then it was like
six people fit at the table I was like
oh I'm only one person I guess I shoulda
spicy wait that's so interesting that
you can get a table out of context it's
actually way more economical to get a
table and you get like wait service yeah
you got a bottle oh we're doing yeah oh
how great how great because front row is
GA but then I was also think maybe I
could do that cuz I'm gonna be standing
the whole time anyway but if if we're a
group I think a table I generally like
hey GA concerts because my body is just
not built for standing um and you have
to get there early if you want to be
somewhat decently positioned and they
they may they wait they say the shows at
eight o'clock she don't go on till 8:30
so for Lady Gaga opening in Vegas TPG
loves GA because he's so tall okay and
it's actually like not fair that he's in
and he's so considerate he always tans
in the back like it's the nicest thing
ever Lady gaga I was like so hyped up
and I wore sneakers and I was prepared
and had a backpack like it was fine but
Kelly Clarkson and Lady Gaga is more of
like a rave moment so I didn't mind
being in like a mosh but Kelly Clarkson
is much more like I would like to stand
there and appreciate her vocal abilities
like I think I would definitely need a
booth I mean for me Kelly Clarkson's a
rave moment so it's restless right and
you know one out of the five shows I
might have to do Molly just because like
of everything I've said we have a lot to
do today you're gonna recap the bachelor
yeah obviously deliver the Fast Five but
something I want to mention yes sir that
we did it was that Jack and I just
wanted to give a major shout out to our
Australian toasters we're going through
the devastate oh the RDH fires it's so
terrible the pictures of the Koala it's
like literally make me want to cry we
just want our Australian toasters to
know that we are here
if you need anything and maybe just
listen to the toast to escape it's so
terrible it's so terrible more with you
we're all thinking of you there are a
lot of Australian toasters though I mean
there has to be at least one which is
enough for me some girl DME Shep she
moved from America to Australia so that
counts that that definitely counts well
very exciting date you in the new set
like the Sun came out thank God special
guest thank God everything special guest
mr. Sun oh my god we should have like
the Sun from Teletubbies also special
guest today making a return to their
amazing where they got their start like
they're huge stars now but they got
their start on the show and they and
they never forget where they come from
is our gavels our gavels we I don't know
if we I don't know if we have any
justice to serve today we'll see where
the stories take us but if we do we have
our custom gavels did Olivia make these
for us uh I think so or maybe a their
custom oh yeah they say award-winning
co-host the morning yeah never forget
where you came from these are so
important I don't even want a new one
even like your color of mine is like so
Doody brown and like yours is so
beautiful pink but whatever it's really
indicative of like our personalities I
just think that these are real like time
capsules yeah I think so far I just want
to serve up justice for me because my
favorite band of all time is coming to
an end I literally feel like Lindsay
Lohan as lowest-ever sir when sidarthur
and at the time I really didn't
appreciate what she was going through I
really didn't I thought she was being
dramatic wearing black I was gonna read
at this time like I too am going on a
hunger strike and gonna keep a box under
my bed until someone buys me tickets to
their farewell show and I have to sneak
on the train with my best friend and
there are many times to sing and then I
have to get a scalper but then I'm gonna
get into the after-party and were gonna
have a grand old time in my dress is
gonna be in a limousine it's gonna jump
to Megan Fox's party are you going back
on purpose I'm wearing all that gifts
because I'm in mourning with cowboy
boots because well very symbolic I just
I love it because the white come home in
a white boot is representative of this
small bit of hope we have left yes and
the purity enjoy that Rascal Flatts has
brought into my life our baskets are
also making a resurgence on the show on
we don't know if we're gonna need them
today this is our basket of people who
deserve justice in case you're new here
people who we think you know in pop
culture in life have just been glossed
over and really didn't get justice
Sharpay and I feel as though ever since
we put those baskets into the universe
all of these people have gone
Meredith Blake is Kathy Dolan has got
sure pay for obvious reasons she's done
her justice has been served what about
custom do you think is justice okay Oh
Meredith Blake from chest up and serve
she's meand at all day every day
hailer she is a knockout justice killer
from the ocean Townsend chances and
finally uh she's got a little bit of
justice Lily from The Princess Diaries
yeah I think justice is being served and
I'd like to see it our other basket just
in case anyone's new here baskets will
be making a comeback this basket is our
basket full of people who we have China
we just really can't it's small because
we're trying to not be so negative I
think we should take Jacob Sartorius out
of it oh no so he by the he is the
reason we started the basket because
taken China is the reason we chose Jacob
sartorius's in here at someone we won't
talk about on the show because he licks
his lips on tick tock and just makes
girls I just I can't
and he also beat me out for People's
Choice Award like few years ago and I'm
still really upset about it blac Chyna's
in here for obvious reasons she's the
reason we invented the term China we
were talking about her all the time on
the show when it was getting frustrating
and then Tristan Thompson I honestly
don't hate Tristan Thompson anymore but
but I hate talking about him me too
they've been China another ten if you
have any suggestions people who need to
go in the basket well I think it's time
just to get right into it don't you
think I definitely think that it is time
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast for sure you know I don't want to
step on anyone's toes but I would be so
upset I would be remiss I would be
devastated I might even be heartbroken
if I didn't let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by MTV
siesta key because the seasons the
season three premiere is tonight on MTV
January seventh that is today at 8 p.m.
eastern Pacific time it is such a good
show we have recapped it many times on
this show and we've had some of the cast
members on which it's been an honor and
a privilege but if you haven't started
watching CSI key you have got to it is
the best show it is fabulous it is sexy
it is breathtaking one might say I'm
TV's highly anticipated hit series
siesta key is back with more drama than
ever before welcoming the bachelorettes
Robbie hey Stu the crew very
controversial add to the cast people
were very very upset about it but after
meeting him and kind of like hearing him
out I actually knees and I sky I agree
the original gang is back with the
dissolution of siesta keys it couple
and Juliet has left the friend circle
divided new cast members invade the
scene bringing conflict heartbreak and
deception to the mix now the newly
minted crew must learn that taking risks
with love and friendship comes with the
cost leaving lovers burned and
friendships irreversibly damaged a
Shakespearean there's just so many
rumors about the cast like on Instagram
like I just wanted the season to start
because I need to know what's true yeah
and Jackie and I also had the privilege
of seeing the first episode and it is
it's shocking it's truly Shakespearean
to say the least it's shocking and some
might even say she experienced
Shakespearean ki make sure you check out
siesta key the season premiere of the
third season is tonight on MTV on that's
January 7th 8 p.m. Eastern Time and
Pacific Robbie Hayes is joining the cast
you don't want to miss it MTV tonight 8
p.m. eastern time check it out check it
out you guys it's it's really good stuff
it's like reality television at its best
it really is and it's also bringing back
like vintage reality television moments
like really reminiscent of like the
hills and like the beautiful Luna Beach
Newport Beach vibe totally ok our first
story which we've already covered is
country music stars Rascal Flatts and
now announced farewell tour after 20
years together and I just feel like a
lot of toasters will be listening to
this and like just not care and that is
why they're breaking up like because
people don't [ __ ] appreciate talent
but then I also feel like everyone loves
Rascal Flatts and everyone even people
who don't like country music Rascal
Flatts has been a part of their lives
maybe it's a graduation song my way life
is a highway like there are so many
things like Rascal Flatts is really so
evergreen what hurts the most what song
are you gonna miss the most nothing the
songs are going anywhere but like what
song for you from Rascal Flatts is like
indicative of why you love them ooh that
is such a great question mine and I only
asked a question because I have an
answer so I'll give you a moment -
summer nights I think that's the best
song ever is where the girls in the
front row singing always oh that's
really that's um but that's not summer
nights yes no it's not
yes it oh no here's to you sorry that's
also sorry my summer nights I love that
song because I'm a nice because that
song was written by Rascal Flatts and I
don't think they even realized that like
they wrote a song about how their music
makes me feel on a summer night yeah you
just let that egg Luke wheeler mark your
piece of paradise like to be so happy
and so fulfilled with like just
cooller like that is a life that I
that's goals that's goals like that is a
simplicity that I aim to have and that I
currently don't have I just I think like
that song in particular like the way it
makes me feel and the actual song is why
I love Rascal Flatts I love that choice
for you I just you it was also a close
runner-up yes I think I'm gonna go with
ooh okay I'm gonna do one like positive
vibe and then like a somber vibe that
just really gets you in your feelings
but I think fast Carson freedom just
such a great song it's like from the
middle of their career it's just like
it's everything and I also believe just
like an important cultural moment that
they use that song and hurry fully
loaded
ooh love that for that love that Lindsay
Lohan movie love that for them and then
I think my favorites sad song that
literally made me cry at one of their
concerts is here comes goodbye oh so sad
what concerts have you cried out that's
a great conversation because I've kind
of one which one really weird because I
had seen her like 4 times in a row that
week Kacey Musgraves something about
like I just really feel I felt a lot of
things I felt really happy for her
because like I'm an OG fan like and I
know
I'll send our family like we will fight
about this till the day we die but like
I introduced her to the family and like
I will take that to my grave and like
I'm an OG fan like not all these
bandwagon earners who were like
Coachella like I didn't really makes me
annoyed but I'm really so happy for her
like so this is like watching her and I
I was in show for my show in Dallas and
like I had had such a big show and like
she was having a big show and it was
just like so happy for women and I was
also like super drunk and like me and
Margaret just having so much fun it was
just like a great night on the road with
my sister and that we were he's
chemically laughing cuz the guy next to
me was like a reporter they gave us like
some of the IP tickets so the guy next
me was like writing a review for like
the local Dallas Gazette and he asked us
to stop singing so loud and honestly I
really brought me down I hate when
people do that and like yes I know I'm
animating but move like sorry that's
your problem like I'm here to enjoy my
life and I was just like all those
writers you know what they should be in
the back to like survey the whole
scenario like don't be in the front row
of singing like with the girls in the
front row singing also me being an
animal is important research for you
like that's how Kacey Musgraves me
rightful feel I'm crying and screaming
like that's important that's a no write
it down jot it down like it's important
great I agree so when um it was follow
your arrow or merry-go-round like one of
her og songs that she plays at the end
like I just got so emotional marker was
like hysterically laughing at me but
I've never cried at a concert before but
it just really made me feel so many
feelings like for her for me like for me
and Margo like for for my family like I
was just
feeling everything love it yeah I'm
happy for you um so it's like I would
say I never cried at a concert um
because I wouldn't remember but like I
cried at Rascal Flatts
here comes goodbye and then I can't
remember any other time if I have but
I'm sure that I have who if you got to
see them in concert who would you cry if
you saw ooh that's a good one I think I
actually maybe also cried at reputation
tour but like that wasn't like an
emotional cry that was just like I was
so overwhelmed yeah I don't know I feel
like I would cry at like Lauren Daigle
at Coachella I'll see you there girl I
feel like I'm cry it like ed her at
Terminal five you know yeah yeah whoo
teller you're too busy like worrying
about your instagrams like oh I'll tell
you where I would cry where where I do
cry then Platt Oh dead four [ __ ]
scenes also I had a huge pit in my
stomach that an hour twenty nineteen
where you have a pisode albums we didn't
include Ben pass out well because you
know what it's not like I can't refer to
it as an album because it's like it's
not like music to me it's like Diaries
like and I can't listen to it it's not
in my playlist I don't have any of the
songs hearted because if they were to
come on like it's triggering I listen to
it I can't believe every flight I can't
listen to it casually I just can't I
listen to it in full it is such a
masterpiece it's it's it's like two
masterful it's poetry it's not even
music and so it's the best poem of 2019
but not album rain his newest song was
like in one of my number ones on my
Spotify analytics oh yeah but that's an
upbeat song yeah he's so great it's so
great
he also um he filmed his show at Radio
City which was on brush Hashanah which
was like low-key so rude cuz he's Jewish
he filmed it for a Netflix special so
we'll be getting that soon and maybe
I'll cry then yeah I'm sure that you
will but it's a sad day in the music
industry and um I'm Rascal Flatts what's
there what are their phantoms
ladee the flatties like we see we hear
you we are there for you and it's
Rascals the rest Kalitta's
it's terrible and I'm sorry that we're
going through this it's truly the end of
an era 1,000% because you know what I
really think of Rascal Flatts I think of
camp we listen to him so much at camp
when I was a counselor and like this
speaker wasn't like my area for like
shower hour I was in charge and I
listened to that album that has changed
on it literally all day every day the
camp
to kill me and I just didn't care oh so
their song unstoppable and then they did
a remix of it for the Olympics and it's
like that's the stuff if you ever just
like feeling like you want to be
inspired to become an Olympian listen to
unstoppable I hope they had a lot of
money I can't imagine how they don't cuz
they've been touring for years for years
their songs are just always life is a
highway alone being in every movie it
has their song oh it's not a cover yeah
damn but I think so many of their songs
God blessed the broken road then they
were happy and it's just like they just
never stop getting us but we didn't
country back it's just a terrible day
here in New York mm-hmm and all over the
world and my hearts are with country
music it's a sad day also we should try
and get them on the toast in 2020 even
though like they're over it like they no
need to do press no they don't they
definitely don't want to talk to us who
like we're just like trying to get them
tight again and they're like just want
to go home and you guys did that thing
like you should totally see together and
they're like [ __ ] totally ok well now
you know that Marasco pot is splitting
up make sure to get your tickets but
fox.com let's save some breath okay next
story a little fun Jewish news Tiffany
Haddish got an extravagant Bat Mitzvah
present from Beyonce's mom oh okay so
Tiffany Haddish was on Jimmy Kimmel Live
recapping her bas Mitzvah and some of
the gifts that she received yeah also
she this is a story from her special I
just watched her special and I want to
talk about that too okay well she talked
about how Barbra Streisand who
unfortunately could not make it gave her
a diamond Jewish star necklace oh is
that what she wore to the Golden Globes
it might be
she wore like a maganda bead necklace on
the Golden Globes and I was like shucks
that's definitely from Barbra Streisand
her hacks and then Jimmy Kimmel was
talking about how he thought the Bat
Mitzvah was like a joke so he came up in
jeans and he got her a gift but he got
her the same thing as Barbra Streisand
just without the diamonds
oh and Tiffany Haddish was like she was
saying that she's gonna wear it quote
I'm aware when I work out and go to
places where I don't want people to feel
like I'm flossing so true so true you
only fancy a Star of David necklace and
like I'm not an see one and then she
shared that Beyonce's mom gave her the
most beautiful Bible so beautiful so in
her special oh that's so different
okay she was talking about how she's
like gained a little bit of weight and
she like just doesn't care but when she
was getting ready for her special like
she didn't know what to wear and she
went to Tina Lawson's birthday party and
Beyonce was wearing this amazing black
jumpsuit and Tiffany Haddish couldn't
stop talking about the black jumpsuit to
everyone so like a week later she was
thinking about what she's gonna wear for
a special check she called it Beyonce's
mom was like how can I get that that
jumpsuit and she's like that so funny
Beyonce was actually gonna give it to
you you were talking so much about it
but I don't think it's gonna fit you
know Beyonce's big booty and yeah
Tiffany's like I think it'll be fine and
then I couldn't believe that she fit
into it because she said she's gained
weight she was being so funny and I just
really wanted to talk about the special
did you watch it no but I know you've
thoroughly enjoyed I really really
enjoyed it and what's so crazy is that
I've and I'm really rigid about special
I really don't like to watch specials
for a million reasons one I feel like
I'll end up stealing a joke just because
it's in my brain and like I just don't
want to be a joke thief but I watched it
and I've spoken to a bunch of people
about it and they like really didn't
like it and I thought it was hysterical
like I was so shocked by her like I've
never seen her do stand-up I've seen her
be funny like in movies and like in
conversations but some people are just
like funny and then some people like or
standup funny like it's different and
then some people are really funny in
standup but then you meet them in person
they're like awkward enough funny yeah
it's just it's hard to be all like me
and Tiffany Haddish is all she was so
funny she was sweating so much in her
Santa because she was being so physical
which I love I thought it was great I
gave it I gave it four stars at the end
she got like really dirty talking about
sex and like that's just not my vibe but
I really enjoyed it and I do give it the
quadric stamp of approval ooh I'm gonna
check it out but I haven't been on
Netflix in a while I know whatever since
friends I literally don't know what ever
since books ever since books friends now
plays I mean it always has played on
Nick at night I like 11:00 but it has
commercials so I've always just like at
11:00 gone to Netflix and the fact that
I don't have that and they know that I
could fix it like I know I could just
buy it on you might on youtube you can
buy it on iTunes I know that I just
don't want to like I just want friends
back okay good luck and I'm standing in
protest like sidarthur with my fellow
friends fans okay
next story just some really cute um some
cute Gwyneth Paltrow news I love some
cute when she's on the cover love some
see
GPN she's on the cover of Harper's
Bazaar blue snatchler which she
naturally is she's the natural and
that's good Thank You Gwyneth Paltrow
says she's quote friendly with ex Brad
Pitt I don't have any bad blood really
thank God
the Oscar winner appears on the February
cover of Harper's Bazaar where she
admits she's still on good terms
it didn't January just start I'll never
understand understand magazines like
coming out three months before and then
I'll also Nevers to understand like
fall/winter Fashion Week being in the
spring like I just don't get it okay I
understand the second part more because
it's like we're seeing the trends for
spring people too like why do they call
it it's just they're like fall fashion
week and it's like in February I just so
get it no it's very confusing and don't
get me started on resort never heard of
it that I'm most commuting it's like a
collection just for people who go on
vacation like I have my vacation clothes
right no no it's called ASOS like it's
not it sounded serious she's on the
cover of Harper's Bazaar where she
admits she's still on good terms with
all of her past loves Paltrow and her
ex-husband Chris Martin chair two kids
apple and Moses and happily co-parent
after separating amicably in 2014 but
one of them her exes is still one of my
best friends one from high school Tony
woods and I'm friendly with Brad Pitt I
don't have any really bad blood like a
horse you did don't like where's Tony
woods right now I hope he sees this
probably at the Paltrow Manor well I
love that her and Brad are still on good
terms I mean like I said we spoke about
this yesterday I don't want her and him
to get back together because I love the
love that she has with Brad pal Chuck I
just love that they're on good terms
because what I just I just stand high
stand so hard um I just need to find the
woman for Brad I know it's so hard it's
well so you know I'm going to Mexico in
a few weeks and that's like my annual
trip with my and Paltrow and I'm like
really hoping she's gonna be there this
year because for two years strong and I
just like need another picture with her
and like she loves me and like I love
her so much you don't talk to her about
it see if she has any friends for her
Brad total imagine like if I did every
time I'm around her I'm like he's gonna
totally never you segment no it's it's
Brad's turn I feel her love you know
like he's been through a lot he's
repented he's changed and this leads me
into my next story because him and Leigh
in the Ardo DiCaprio went on a podcast
what yep wait is it Joe Rogan nope
very similar Marc Maron
Brad Pitt jokes he has a quote disaster
of a personal life in podcast with Leo I
kick I saw this head boy and I was like
Brad Pitt is doing podcasts you guys we
are in the right industry ah he was it
sponsored by Sanford no but it should
have been but this one is today's
episode is also brought to you by
sensible Sanford have you ever gotten up
to someone and asked you smell amazing
what perfume you're wearing happens to
me all the time ever since I started
using Sanford I have tried okay so
Sandberg is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes they have more than 600
designer brands for you to choose from
it's pretty genius you choose the
perfume you want to try they'll send you
a 30 day supply fancy designer perfumes
are super expensive so they'll send you
like it's not a travel size because it's
actually a lot bigger than you would
expect it lasts you I think it's 120
sprays it's more than enough for a month
if you like it you can reorder it the
next month you could try something new I
have tried many perfumes I've been
loving the mountain goats one which is a
new addition to the separate
subscription service besides family the
separate family I just extend word it's
like the most genius company ever and I
can't believe it wasn't haven't existed
before and now they are carrying
products from other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup they carry
brands like Coke re which is a favorite
here at the toast glam glow glow recipe
tart and so many others we have an
exclusive offer for our listeners you
can get 30% off your first month today
that's only ten dollars for your first
fragrance go to our offer has change to
make sure you listen because I know a
lot of the toasters have been using the
old one its scent berg calm / steam the
promo code is Steen ste en for 30% of
your first month so the link is sent
bird comm scen TBI RDECOM slash teen
sign up and use our promo code Steen ste
n to try your first perfume or cologne
for just $10 that's 30% off your first
month sign on smell amazing love scent
bird thanks for sponsoring this episode
and thanks for keeping me smelling I
mean in a good way
love tempered so much um okay Brad Pitt
Brad Pitt knows how to poke fun at
himself the Golden Globe winner recently
joined his once upon a time in Hollywood
co-star leo on the what the [ __ ] with
Marc Maron podcast which debuted on
Monday I mean I'm not a I've never
listened to the show so I don't know if
it's called WTF it's gotta be GF Oh WTF
with Marc Maron I cannot but I'm gonna
listen to this episode because like I
saw this headline this morning and I
read the article and it's like obviously
the person who wrote this article
only read another article about it and
everyone's just clipping the same one
line but it's like when you had Brad
Pitt and Leo on a podcast like I need it
transcribed my friends I just like I
cannot believe that they did a podcast
this is like well I'm obviously jealous
I'm actually really happy for Marc Maron
I love it for the media right this is a
huge moment for podcasters a huge moment
for the medium it's a huge moment for
the Long Island medium huge it's huge
Maron asked the stars at what point they
knew they'd hit the big leagues in their
respective careers Leo said the moment
came after he made quote a film called
Titanic and noticed he was being
followed by four black SUVs one day Wow
when DiCaprio said that no longer
happens quite as frequently Pitt
expressed his surprise saying it doesn't
I'm a little disgruntled with you Pitt
joked I'm just like trash mag fodder I
don't know maybe because of my disaster
of a personal life probably we get so
funny that he knows he's like tabloid
trash somebody I use he'd add a
self-aware King okay so a list yet he's
like it's so true that had a line on the
National Enquirer by the way now that I
think about it the tech like the I've
never really thought of he is probably
one of the most Eila stars in the world
and appears on the cover of trash
magazines more than anyone I don't think
but I guess that's similar to like Harry
and Megan and Katie yeah it's like
another stratosphere of Fame and like
leo doesn't appear on the cover but it's
also this is personally I guess it's
kind of sorted but it's I guess not yeah
it's just it's definitely less messy he
doesn't have like messy breakups he just
goes through women a lot kind of like
George Clooney he's a very similar to
George Clooney and I don't think George
Clooney was on the cover of Star
magazine every week but I also think the
less stars on social media so like Brad
Pitt and the Royals the more they're
gonna be on the cover of tabloids
because that's the only way fans get to
hear about them I just like I cannot
believe that Brad Pitt knows that he's
like tabloid trash like the fact that he
just said that read it to me again
whether you say she said I'm a little
disgruntled with you I'm just like trash
bag fodder I don't know because of my
disaster of a personal life probably I
love it it's so true because like
between Jenn and then and then Angelina
and the divorce like it's so much it's
so much love that oh my god I hope I'm
gonna listen to the podcast today I'm
really excited it's actually crazy how
he can be like dragged into so much of
that trash and not have it affect his
career at all like he's still a megastar
well yeah I mean it's better for his
career because being like if you're not
being talked about or whatever they say
right relevancy is everything yeah it's
just it's so crazy
it's so crazy I need to see knives out
like now you do and I also need to see I
know also didn't see once upon a time in
Hollywood but it was written for me by
or mom oh she was just like Barry and
what did you feel like I I feel like I
were in the movie like a million times
free now oh no once you found out oh I
won't ruin it cuz I'm not anyway but
once it found out you should still see
it it's so beautiful
no I want to it looks so beautiful like
I know what happens but like it's
beautiful which also I know we talked
about the global Globes are so long
yesterday but we didn't talk about two
things
okay oh actually just one thing um
Quentin Tarantino okay um they're like
rumors that he's like so crazy but he
seemed to be like so well-spoken and
like he's a pregnant wife and I thought
he was like so cute and by the way he
ended the speech in Hebrew yeah I feel
like with most like geniuses people say
that they're crazy and then you hear
from them and it's like oh he's fine
right like Joaquin Phoenix and Kanye
right yeah yeah you know so I feel like
you're not a genius unless people are
saying that you're crazy well nobody
said about us do I think that they do
we're so crazy you guys justice for us
just an excuse to use my gavel okay I go
oh man I feel like that's happened to me
before
yeah are you ready for a fifth and final
story well so fast yes because we have
to recap The Bachelor um it's a little
uh meatless news we love a story here
about a meatless industry
I love the meatless industry and I'm
learning really more and more from
Joaquin Phoenix about the impact of
Agriculture on the climate and how being
a vegetarian is like great for the world
and I just feel as though I've been
doing it for ten years now and I feel
like I'm really contributing I just
think I don't want to blow up your spot
it's worth mentioning that you are not a
vegetarian like that but I eat I may be
I may be eaten meat like maybe once a
month really yeah
I never
even when I have a chance to eat kosher
meat I'm just like not a huge meat-eater
it's so crazy [ __ ] ain't gonna catch
flack for this I just [ __ ] love me
and and that's I'm happy for you like
I'm not gonna judge your choices but I'm
just proud of myself that like I'm
actually doing something you're happy
for me
know that I am know that I am I'm not
judging your choices Hooters debuts
meatless chicken wings after first
testing them on Hooters girls Wow
move over impossible burger it's unreal
wings it's time to shine Hooters just
launched meatless chicken wings in 318
restaurants nationwide in a partnership
with qu ORN corn I guess that's like a
new I'm editor beyond me it's a possible
burger exciting I love to see it
competition is great for the consumer
according to a press release the unreal
wings are quote vegetarian non-gmo soy
free and sustainably produced the new
menu option is fried and can be served
with any own Hooters 14 signature sauces
or dry rub you know who's gonna be
really [ __ ] excited about this then
I'm so excited about this I mean we have
to go to Hooters
um just there one in the city there is
one it's sorry I misspoke there is one
they know how I know about it it used to
be where route 57 is right next door are
you sure positive because Ben told me a
hilarious story when he was in the tenth
grade and we spoke about this on the
show how when Ben was growing up his mom
drove him everywhere like just school
and he had a birthday party in tenth
grade one of the kids like had a
birthday party at Hooters when they were
like look like gonna organize birthday
party was like was go to Hooters and so
Ben was trying to go but his mom
insisted on driving him Ben made his mom
drop him off at route 57 but that's
Toronto funny internet any time I passed
for 57 I laugh because Ben's never eaten
there he's just been dropped off there
and then Ben's mom picked him up there -
I have a funnier story about route 57 in
some jewelry it's rebecca's she just
told it to me recently it's really funny
really seven by the way if you don't
know it's a huge restaurant on the
corner of 57th and six it has been
around for at least 15 years nothing in
New York says mother it's been around
since I've been alive right nothing in
New York stays in business it's
definitely a front because it's so weird
I've never seen anyone eat there and
it's like a tourist trap it's just very
confusing very confusing but Rebecca was
living in the city one summer she's not
from here
and I think she was going on a date and
someone was like someone chose her 57
and she they were like let's meet up
room 57 and she didn't know that that
was a restaurant so she thought it was
like rue like Street Kings Street I just
like being pretenses and she like went
to pizza oh my god why didn't she ever
go on a date with someone who she
thought renounce me me I'm 57 I don't
know oh my god I'm happening money is
story I've ever heard
told you so rue 57 is just so deeply
entrenched in in history and toaster II
oh my god that's the best story ever
yeah room 57 I forgot that rooming
Street in French uh-huh
hilarious hilarious I mean that's why
it's a great name for the restaurant cuz
it is on Rue 57 Oh totally
Wow now I think I'm understanding why
she's a 57 okay now that we've spoken
about it so much if like someone from
the PR department doesn't reach out for
us a free meal will do a patreon video
someone doesn't reach out not for us to
free meal we'll go and pay for yeah
never we have to record it for patreon
oh of course
also we have a great patron episode
coming out this week it's oh yes we do
but we also have one that went up
yesterday a vlog chronicling us setting
up our new studio honestly that I think
a lot of his I know saying because like
looking at all the boxes and like where
we started I think there are a lot of
interesting factoids for people and
you'll really see the scope of the
studio and then you'll start to see more
of as our new furniture comes in and
we're just gonna like expand yeah we're
not gonna hide from you which is so ugly
right now with boxes and like random
wires everywhere we just want to make it
nice animal share no but like soon we'll
have couches and these chairs will be
gone we got such good stuff society6
which is one of the sponsors of our show
they sent us such good stuff they have a
lot of toasty items I think there's a
lot of palm trees so it's very exciting
check out patreon not calm such the
morning toast leave a lot of good stuff
coming up we have camcos tickets coming
out soon busy January like I said I
think I would look back on the searing
realize China mine was my most important
months of my life well making counts
this that's time saying yes to life
I'm gonna watch happens live tonight
which like is theoretically really fun
but like you don't get home till like
1:00 in the morning so I'm gonna be so
ugly entire tomorrow but Jackson Britney
are on and they invited me which was
it's okay if you're ugly and hair just
make sure like you come with some good
tea yes of course so that like it's all
worthwhile watched others ivory sling
has been on it like
times because Andy's like a new dad and
the network is really like working with
him so I hope it's on at 10 o'clock
tonight has anything on Bravo tonight
Dana prompt Girls premiere oh right oh
my god I have to watch out I can't leave
its back ready I'm like not ready I feel
ready but there's so much on right now
which leads us to our next segment where
we are going to recap about Sur because
we both watched the three hour premiere
last night night so many thoughts in so
many cringes we're gonna do a quick
recap if you want a really in-depth
episode this is a new episode of the
snatchler a touch News Network show
which is our podcast I'm gonna can speak
podcasts it is our bachelor podcast
hosted by our sister Margo and her
friend Nicole
it is great check it out iTunes Spotify
did you see Margot and Nicole's text
exchange yesterday yeah I had nobody
what they were talking about because I
felt I missing you see what Nicole said
like stick to the bachelor oh my god
I've been texting her that every minute
of the day so we are gonna recap the
bachelor and that recap is brought to
you I knew a favorite here getting in
shape doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale it's about building
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself very true if fitting into
a favorite pair of jeans is your goal
great but there are many reasons you
might want to practice self-care and
every person is different it's hard to
get fixated on a number everybody like
about newman's that it's not about that
it's just about like bettering yourself
and I was feeling like you're moving in
the right direction just taking care of
yourself so if you want to exhibit
better self-care you want to feel more
confident in your clothing which is
definitely something I never really
cared about my weight I just care about
like how I feel like my jeans right now
are digging into my bellybutton that's
how I know it's like been a bad week for
me um noon is a habit changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses it is based in
psychology they help you teach you why
you do the things that you do and it
empowers you with the tools you need to
break bad habits and replace them with
better ones Numis is not a diet very
important it is a healthy and easy to
stick to way of life no food on Numis
considered bad good or off-limits
the key to moderation and can be used in
conjunction junction what's your
function with many preexisting popular
diets if you want we're all strapped for
time Newman's just asking you to commit
10 minutes a day for yourself they have
one of the biggest and most accurate
food databases available that lets you
track your meal habits visualize portion
sizes and see calorie density at a
glance your human the best part about
noon is that if you go off track it's
literally not a big deal there is
absolutely no shaming they just give you
tips to help you get back on track
tomorrow you could chat with a co
specialist and the entire
community to get and give help to people
going through the same thing you don't
have to change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noon calm /
toast what do you have to lose visit new
mom / toasts to start your trial today
that's Noom and um calm / toast sign on
and change your life love it
sign on feel amazing actually smell
amazing let's talk about the bachelor
before we even go into it I don't think
we've ever given our thoughts on just
Peter in general like what we thought
about him being about sure I have
absolutely no thoughts about him yeah
he's fine he's super cute and it's like
Nick vile part to him and now that I'm
in Nick vile Stan love to see thick file
yeah he's so thick file also there was a
lot of backlash but he was chosen
because mike johnson who was a very
eligible bachelor they really could have
finally had their first black bachelor
they did it and then I think they in the
first episode really leaned on Peter
being a quarter human it just seemed
like a little force and I don't want to
like mock the Cuban culture at all
because it's beautiful on the food and
the day and I totally get it but I just
think they definitely amped that up a
little bit for sea vibe yeah with the
food and the density in the kitchen and
the guy obviously don't know if Peter
speaks Spanish because no and then it's
like they really like drove it home in
that one instance but then it doesn't
come up ever again it's all about like
his culture is being a pilot the the
pilot jokes totally the flight
attendants the paper airplanes totally
it was out of control
but I think he's cute he's very
well-spoken he's very handsome I didn't
really realize he definitely like
trimmed up before the bachelor cuz he
looked really cute really snatched every
outfit they put him in he looks like a
pilot like brown mother jacket white
t-shirt aviator glasses and I think he's
a great bachelor because it's like he's
not so crazy good-looking you know movie
star that it's like this guy just is
gonna be an LA staple and famous it's
never gonna work out I think he he
really gives me the vibe that he wants
to settle down and that makes the show
go that makes you able to digest the
show and maybe believe in it after
watching I was realizing I have a very
hard time reading him like I can't tell
if he's ever really into someone or not
into someone which will make it
interesting because I don't I really
immediately don't know like any real
frontrunner um I just I can't get a vibe
off of him like he's a very polite you
know and he kisses everyone oh my god
the kissing the girl who showed up out
of the limo by
folded him and kissed him like really
made me uncomfortable and I did not
think it was acceptable he was so nice
about it and then he like post kiss
consented but I was just like not here
for you that's not how like that's not
how I first kissed goes in the words of
Karen humor contact without consent is
that okay is giving me like Sierra
Burgess is a loser vibes is a
blindfolded notice in Kenny oh and that
was like so unproblematic agreed agreed
and so that kiss was I found to be very
problematic like we should maybe get a
kiss in the first episode maybe too
exciting stuff but like to everyone
kissed her to claim one out of the limo
is obscene the first episodes of all
these shows but especially the bachelor
gives me so much anxiety like so many
girls in one room so many personalities
crazy competitive girls like you know
the type of girl that goes on the batch
or like she is not like she is
unabashedly herself like I just get so
much anxiety like hey you're not being
able to keep up with anyone I literally
don't know anyone's name I'm gonna
mispronounce everyone's name and I'm
just gonna describe that based on their
looks today which is so rude but I'm
sorry like how can you know anything I
think I know for people's names and it's
the people who I think are the biggest
frontrunner Hannah and Madison Kelly
who's the fourth ahh Victoria oh the
girl in the jumpsuit I want to say her
name was Lisa what jumpsuit she wore a
black lace jumpsuit long sleeve and
Peter commented on the on the on the
jumpsuit he's like that's a power suit
she's gonna be the most beautiful girl
I've ever called her hair but black but
it's hard because she literally was
irrelevant to the episode but she's the
most beautiful girl is it Sydney you
know I'm just like I should bring up the
contestants anyway because Sydney's
really pretty
also jasmine and okay I'm lost now oh
and of course I know McKenna cringe
fashion blogger ugliest dress why that's
like Silas who means to arrest yourself
Jackie and I always judging me the
funniest joke like three years ago that
I can't get over it was ugly last year
there was a stylist who came on her name
was Tracy and they kept showing stylist
in every outfit was worse than the next
and it's like she's awful and I think
she showed up like at the Fashion Police
and she needed to put those cuffs on her
wrists and walk out because this style
was not there okay I'm gonna bring up
the contestants because it's truly it's
too hard it's like every time I do this
I and the other Victoria I know her
because like she's so annoying oh my god
oh my god I wish you were still like I
don't have time for
her.she okay first all she wouldn't stop
crying this the first episode is always
so difficult because you run into the
same narrative girls yelling at other
girls for taking up their time it's like
sorry [ __ ]
Hana aunt didn't come here to help you
Shane to to get time but it is changing
a little bit because it used to be
whoever interrupted the most was like
automatically the villain but now it's
like the more are you interrupts like
the more you really want it and she's
going about it in such a sweet way even
though I feel as I really like her and
she's so cute and obviously she's a
front-runner she got the first
impression rose
but there is something coming with Hana
am because like she's not a sweetie she
seems there's something really conniving
about her and I looked forward to it
because I I I scanned a multi-faceted
girl she's 23 she's from Knoxville
Tennessee and she is a model I really
like Hannah Ann and I know people are
like weird about her I think the
conversation she had when I can't he
mispronouncing this girl's name it
reminded me of the website she in Oh
shine I think her name is no that's the
website no she him his website I think
your name is shine okay when she pulled
her over and was like basically yelling
at Hannah for the fact that shine got no
time excuse me bless you which I just
hate that converse are you getting sick
also no oh my god why oh I'm sick I'm
sick
um I hate that conversation like in no
way is it anyone's fault but your round
that you even get enough time if Anna's
getting a managing to get enough time
and all these other girls are managing
to get enough time that's on you I hate
that conversation that happened last
year and it's happening again
um but I think Hannah handled it
perfectly she said you know I really
feel like I want time and how does like
yeah I want that for you too I mean she
literally flipped it like this girl down
the knees she it was it was so crazy to
watch like it was the sweetest
manipulation of all time and like I had
you no choice but to respect that so
hard it's like she almost practiced it
was it was it was the perfect response
if anyone's ever coming for you like
just take a page out of Hannah Ann's
book let's talk about Kelly she's 27
from Chicago she's the one who met Peter
previously okay and she's the only one
that I found so far to be a full-blown
toaster look her and I was gonna say
good things about her anyway it's gonna
say good things about her at first I was
like when she stepped out of the limo
when they had met at a wedding I was
getting PTSD through this okay the PTSD
because Liz was one of the cringy
asterick ters it was that Nick I made
you feel dirty with that but she really
made the best of it like and it became
such an advantage for her right it could
have been so awful she has a genuine
perfectly but I need to know more about
the timeline so she had already been
cast and then she met him yeah she went
up to him she's like hi Peter like I
know this is so weird but they won't say
the full story
she said they won't say that either but
I'm pretty sure she had read even Cass
wasn't sure she was gonna go Ranas and
lobby said oh my god this is so crazy
but I'm supposed to be on your season I
think they had an instant connection
maybe they smooth today obviously dance
I don't think they thought they I think
that would be cleared up for different
parties so I don't even know if they did
she was at a wedding and he was at his
reading then they were like dancing and
saying like just like that night no I
know I think they're really cute and I
don't even care that she cheated those
girls like I hate when girls complain
about not playing fair like [ __ ] this
is the Olympics it's a bachelor like she
cheated I really did they were gonna
penalize her for cheating but like I
what score do you wanna know why because
he who did he beat who did she beat
shiny shiny like they have no chemistry
like we didn't need to see a one-on-one
with them she's not a frontmatter
she's insane she also hurt her out of
the limo thing was very inappropriate
getting in the TSA PreCheck like saying
you know uh pat-down oh my god so many
out of the limo things were awful yes it
was stupid that she cut and she
shouldn't have gotten it because rules
are rules
but what did we need to see him having a
date with someone whom he didn't even
she's not she's irrelevant right and he
said like I was hoping that you would
win of course and she did what she had
to do for the man that she loves and I
stand Kelly no I really do - I think
she's gonna go really far I think that
they have a great connection already and
I loved how she turned the negative of
meeting him before into a positive let's
talk about the people are saying that
she's so creepy and like I wasn't any
good
I was very getting very capable vibes
from her I think she's mature like I
like kind of a man she's 22
she's this girl's 27 she's ready you
know for that moment in her life I
really like him Hannah and is ready to
revolve around the world right she's not
energy yeah maybe a little boo hoo
around the world um but I don't think
she's you're not exactly why the
tutorial it's so true I don't think she
wants to be though so that's fine now
the girl who threw up I believe her name
is Kylie
Victoria Victoria lonner I think she
could win she's so beautiful I think she
could win me too and she's so short
glasses like she's very naturally
beautiful and you know what I realized
when Peter sent girls home night one is
that he
not he's not attracted to like a lot of
plastic surgery like all the girls with
the biggest lips
yeah we're Stockholm yeah that's
interesting really interesting I think
he's gonna end up with a brunette he
gives me brunette vibes ooh I think a
dirty blonde well cuz that's Hannah
which we'll talk about in a minute um
next time once you're home I don't even
want to talk about it I know Madison the
raisin of our generation I have no
choice but to stand
I liked her before she even got to the
mansion cuz I can't believe she's a
basketball player like that is so cool
her dress was literally down to her
about crack in the back and her booty is
amazing like not to you know objectify
women but she looked amazing she looks
amazing personality so positive amazing
date I love that band
and I'm homeboy she really felt to me
like Raven I had the same joy like the
same chemical released in my brain it's
the Raven Jean McKenna I know really
nothing happened for her besides she was
abashed mugger who wore an ugly dress
she's also I believe friends with
Kaitlyn Bristowe I think that might be
the case I saw Kaitlyn Bristowe posted
that her friend was gonna be on and then
someone posted it in snatch our nation
saying it was McKenna so I don't know
100% but Oh Cheyenne that was the girl's
name Shi a and n she is on par for tweet
my least favorite person ever attitude
was so bad she got into fights one she
came for Hannah and then she was like
complaining that she lost like a
two-year-old really you're complaining
in her you don't have enough time with
Peter so you gonna stand here yelling at
Kelly that she cheated on the tricycle
go talk to Peter right you should be the
first one to steal him also I think my
least favorite right now is the other
Victoria who like with her dry sense of
humor no matter what the time that joke
was so hard why would she appear and he
forgot thank you a favor
oh my god if you're gonna do something
so disgusting like you have to have the
courage of your convictions like you
have to stand by that statement you have
so much time it's not like they just
telling you what to do I'm in it before
you get another limo you plan that Chad
so you knew you were gonna be disgusting
and you read with it and then you're you
have the nerve to be ashamed you did
that seniors oh no ashamed and and
reiterate yeah oh and then he forgot and
you're over here reminding him awful I
really didn't like her and then she was
just crying like she's just such a whiny
little weenie
yeah just didn't like her she's she's
not my cup of tea
no she's Victoria act okay Toria P is
the one we like and when she was saying
like I want to meet
taury f it's like Victoria P is gonna
win so soon she'll be the big I love
Victoria P she's I don't know anything I
don't know anything about who wins but I
was getting winning vibes from Victoria
because a lot of these girls they shine
bright and they shine fast like Hannah
Ann but then it burns out she was giving
me Brit vibes from Krystal season where
it was like that chemistry was
undeniable she's so beautiful
but then she's not getting along with
some of the girls and there's more to it
um where is it some of those sleeper
candidates who throw up on the first
date and I I can't have no choice but to
relate to emotion stick to its Queen and
he kissed her a few hours later which is
really sweet and like to make a big deal
of it like I would not have done that
ya know I I think i'ma put we should do
we should do bed yeah but I think we
need one more episode yeah it's like I
loved how they spent the third hour just
getting right into the season and they
didn't give us a first hour of like Ben
Higgins and and Colton coming and giving
him advice I [ __ ] hate that but what
we did get was how to be literally 500
times and it's hard for me because I
totally disagree with Margaret Margo was
hanabi's number one fan and just like me
so sorry I totally understand and
respect speed respect Peter's decision
like why should he believe that Hannah
really has any real feelings for him not
only did she send him home then when she
had the chance to make it right she
chose to go out with Tyler after not
only did she she got proved wrong by
Chad because Jed was a [ __ ] who was
using her and then she realized she made
a decision and let the good bad guy go
and then chose to go out with Tyler
then he buddy like Peters not even
second fiddle right he's not even a
question
don't even turn on conversation yeah and
then she moves to LA he lives in
Westlake doesn't even tell her he's like
why should I believe now no it's like
Hannah and him definitely had something
special but now he has 30 Hannah's in
the house like Carl's who are beautiful
who are from the south like everything
Peter likes like there's a meet there
are a million Hannah's right now and now
he could be a star now it's like Oh
Hannah's so famous right now now it's
like oh Peters gonna be me I'm gonna be
by the time Peter season is over but she
let the best guy go that was a percent
but it like even though a lot of people
think Tyler was the best guy he was
definitely the most handsome but he's
not the best boyfriend material he's
gonna be a star he's gonna be a lot of
the best guy for her like Peter well I
only I watched the last two episodes of
Hannah season with the fantasy suites
and like I knew that she should have
chose Peter right here with his eyes for
her Oh in the windmill jokes oh my god
oh my god so so cringeworthy and her on
the standing there like Wilma God saying
the story like oh my god and I know
people are saying like ABC has these
ironclad contracts we've never seen
someone have to do that before and no
one's making her cry those tears and
like basically ask for him back like it
was just he's gonna be a no from me I
don't I don't know what else to say no I
think kinda really needs to move on for
if she really is amazing was so toxic
for Hannah like she needs just step away
from ever she needs to step away if ABC
really wants to like keep putting her on
TV like she can be the Bachelorette
again and that I would be fine with that
but just like let Peter go because he
wasn't eating her second choice right
and it's honestly it's like she's made
me call him Luke P nobody think of all
the guys and I didn't even watch but
watching paradise after Hannah season
was so shocking because all these really
really handsome guys kept coming down
and they're like Oh Hannah season Hannah
season so Mike of all the guys and then
I know about Tyler and I know about
Peter and then Connor loved him of all
the guys my Johnson you chose Jed
right right so it's a net Tom that
speaks to you and then um that's on you
like that's just your problem at this
point yeah I and then you chose Tyler
see and it didn't work out because he
chose gigi hadid
of course and then you choose heater so
I just I can't deny oh don't her
standing up and you're gonna try and
have us think that she's like into her
dancing partner alright and is she
really gonna get in the house there's no
way I think we're both getting I think
if she got in the house like that would
be one of the saddest things that were
like she can't do that she I don't think
that she will and really she doesn't
because she was doing Dancing with the
Stars the girls hater it would just I
don't think that she will I think maybe
what the best-case scenario would be he
goes through the whole process realized
he doesn't feel as strongly for anyone
as he does for Hannah B and they could
get together or here's my theory because
ABC has said that reality Steve and all
the spoiler websites like will not get a
spoiler the season like they're standing
true they have challenged everyone's
saying there will be no spoilers this
season so if a regular girl wins there
are ways everyone always finds out but
if nobody wins and then he goes to
Hannah like maybe that's the way nobody
would find out so look so few people
know about it I don't know I I I'm not
familiar enough with the spoilers
because I don't read them so I don't
know what would have to happen for there
to be no spoilers
um so yeah I bet I I would be down for
Hannah to be the Bachelorette again I
just feel like it's such a special
opportunity like all like okay yeah a
lot of people on the show day Thursday I
feel for her yeah
why look just because like she seems
genuinely like a really sweet person who
wants to find love I think she's really
unhappy like everyone who gets to this
level of Fame so quickly after The
Bachelor so overwhelming but at least
they have a partner to go through
Dancing with the Stars and she wins and
now she's doing Dancing with the Stars
tour and it's so so much and like she
doesn't have anyone she doesn't have the
one thing she showed up for which was
love she seems so unhappy I totally and
she also seems like a genuinely nice
big-hearted person and I don't want
unhappiness for her no not at all so
that's why I feel for her but but don't
take it out on these thirty girls in
Peter and bring them down with you when
you made the wrong choice not once but
twice three times on three times when
you didn't calm when you move to
Westlake right terrible you know and
like what about some waterproof mascara
huh oh that was that was what they did
to her was not okay like like give her a
minute give her a Neutrogena wipe like
come on I don't know why wear mascara
every single day and I cry a lot that's
never happened to me everything she also
puts her hands on her eyes and like
brushes her eyelashes breath almost like
to be more dramatic yeah totally
the picture of you and Theo so cute it
really is having excited for when the
studio expand horizontally we do well I
feel like that was a really in-depth
recap so who do you got four top four so
I definitely think Madison I definitely
think Kelly
I definitely think Hannah an but she
might turn into a bill in um and for
spate spot is still up for debate but I
think the girl who vomited what was her
nick - yeah yeah yeah I think Victoria
Kelly Madison I think Victoria F will
turn into a huge villain I know a
spoiler about her that I won't ruin is
she the chase price girl I don't think
that's a spoiler yeah and she's had some
one-on-one yep and he spoke to us about
that saying he really felt if you didn't
watch our CMA red carpet just watch the
part with chase rice if you're about
Japan because he performed on The
Bachelor which a lot of country
up-and-coming country stars do
and he told us like he felt like he was
totally set up because he used to date
Victoria I'm like they weren't like kind
of talking when she went on the bats are
like it's a whole shady think she's
really shady I don't like I mean she
gets the one-on-one yeah and she's the
won't but I think it's gonna be like at
the height of her villain ISM I'm like
then you'll get more content where you
just hate her and then the chase where I
said it all makes you really hate her
and then he sends her home to me that
she can see my villain to me she just
seems like an uninteresting television
character no she seems like a like where
I just think we're gonna find out things
you don't really like about her like
she's gonna be like a girl who's not
here to make friends so cool so tragic
okay well there's no episode tonight
right three hours I mean what nerve what
nerve couldn't believe it well that's
all she wrote you guys thanks so much if
you want more bachelor content head to
the snatchler i want to hear her
thoughts on on the girls cuz I feel like
I really disagree with her on every she
is a totally different take on Hannah
then she's like a Hannah apologist which
I totally understand I'm a Bethenny
Frankel apologist I'm a Kardashian
apologist I totally got it I I do get it
sort of I got a two and she loves Hannah
am the snatchler I like her too so far
she hasn't done anything to make me
think you're your trepidatious affair of
what you think might happen but so far
nothing has happened completely agreed
she's just handling herself like a
little too perfectly which it just makes
you think like she's yeah yeah thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning to us and lenio morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
leave a comment we're also available as
a podcast pretty much anywhere podcasts
can be found so it spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i her videocast
box all the places so wherever you find
your podcast find us subscribe leave a
five star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much we are praying for our our
australian toasters we hope you guys are
doing okay we love you thank you so much
have a great day have a good one